i know this must feel
very strange but ordinary
is just what you're used to this
may not seem ordinary to you right now
but after a time it will
this will become ordinary
aunt lydia from the handmaid's tale and
this
is an awful book cover so i'm going to
use my luscious hardcover version of the
testaments instead
antler deer from the handmaid's tale is
not the psychopath that we're
comfortable watching like
hannibal lichter precisely because we
know he's fictional and you aren't
filled with awe when she steps onto the
screen like darth vader our lydia uses
very real abusive tactics in a way that
gets really hard to watch
especially because we see her and the
awful people around us
and you know what she's even worse in
the books
we will be discussing abuse and how it
works in this video both in families and
in relationships if you aren't
comfortable with that that's totally
okay but i recommend not watching this
video this video is part of the one
what is it this villainous scene
playlist where a bunch of us creators
got together talk about great scenes
with great villains link below go watch
the handmaid's tale is a dystopian novel
based in the republic of gilead a
theocratic patriarchal america in which
the few women who can still give
birth are made into handmaids passed
around the ruling class and forced to
bear their children
against their will aunt lydia is the
woman at the top of it all who
brutalizes them into this role listen to
just her first line in this
scene they were dirty women
they were [ __ ] but you
are special girls this is a very common
tactic that abusers will use to control
their victims
children family friends partners that
will make the victim feel special but
not because of any of their own
achievements anything to do with them
personally but because the abuser
chose them out of everyone this can
understandably feel
gratifying that you're special and
chosen especially to someone with low
self-esteem but it also means that the
abuser gets to decide if the victim
is living up to their special standard
and if the victim speaks up or deviates
from any of that
then the abuser is perfectly positioned
to make them feel ungrateful
especially after they were so lucky to
have ended up where they are
now on lydia does this over and over
throughout the story
oh you are so lucky
so privileged guilt becomes a powerful
weapon
against the victim the whole time
there's this deeply uncomfortable
implication
that disobedience is a personal offense
to aunt lydia
like it's rejecting a gift and it's
assumed that you have to defend yourself
against that
secondly the scene juxtaposes affection
and punishment and lydia goes from
electrocuting janine to gently stroking
the face of another girl within an
instant
with a promise of understanding how they
feel
it's whiplash and it does two things
when a relationship can
so quickly turn to violence like that
you are afraid to ever push the
boundaries you are walking on
eggshells even when they're being kind
you're always one word away from them
coming after you and secondly it creates
this toxic relationship with affection
this illusion
of affection really because that
affection isn't coming from any love for
who
you are but from you conforming to who
they
expect you to be but if that's the only
affection you get
it can start to feel like it's not worth
being yourself anymore
lastly aunt lydia infantilizes the women
who become handmaids
welcome to the friggin loony bin right
all right girls
we will have silence like little mice
girls she calls them not women and
likens them to little mice
and you'll notice they're in a classroom
like children the only women she ever
refers to are those that came from that
decadent
dying immoral american society that came
before
gilead how this abusive tactic works is
that the abuser will place themselves on
a wise pedestal
and they will treat any disagreement
they have with their partner or
child whoever it may be as a result of
them just not
fully understanding everything as well
as they do yet
it's very minimizing it's the
implication that
they just don't know enough to make
their own decisions in this particular
matter hammer that now long enough and
they might just believe it
they'll conflate disagreement and your
emotions with you not having the
maturity to understand here
and they'll use there to justify
deciding things for you
how you use your body how you use your
money who you should be friends with
because you don't have the wisdom and
experience they do and you can
only be right through them abusers like
aunt lydia work to undermine the
victim's sense of agency and
decision-making abilities to make them
doubt themselves to make them more
dependent on them for validation
almost so they can approve their
decisions this can result in something
called enmeshment where
a relationship lacks clear physical and
emotional boundaries
all to justify deeper control and
interference
because you don't know what you really
want need or feel
they'll say in this scene aunt lydia has
broken down the boundaries we would
normally have with others
she takes any attempt to assert a
boundary as a rejection
of this twisted kind of care she has for
them
enmeshed people like the handmaid's
partners or children
are easily abused because they find it
difficult to assert themselves and
any kind of boundary and the abuser does
not respect it because they view
themselves as entitled to cross it
that it's pushing them out of their
lives or being unfair we've always done
this way before
so much of abuse is how the abuser is
able to
control how issues and problems in a
relationship
are framed and we see that in the scene
over and over cruelty is framed as
doing what is best for them that it's
their responsibility
that it's only fair and if you have any
problems
it can never be framed as you being
legitimately hurt
it can only be that you're being selfish
weak
dumb or vindictive but
where in the showa lydia is a
domineering physically present force
right from the start for a long time
in the book she's a ghost a
shadow checking every one of alfred's
thoughts
a lady is mentioned 28 times across 80
pages by offering nearly a quarter
of the book before we ever meet her in
the flesh
and it's nearly always offered thinking
about doing something and remembering
how aunt lydia told her she needs to
look
feel and act i also know better than to
say yes
modesty is invisibility said aunt lydia
never forget it
to be seen to be seen is to be
her voice trembled penetrated
what you must be girls is impenetrable
she called us girls wherein the showa
lydia is first presented as someone to
be contended with in a way
in the book antladia has kind of
already won you might say
there's this illusion of being fine of
safety there's only ever the implication
of violence but it's always there
she's inside her mind even when she's
not there
alidia's words are kind and affirmative
describing them as special
and valued likening them to beautiful
flowers
but there's always this deeply
manipulative and uncomfortable feeling
that violence is only ever one mistake
away
what we see in offred is this really
difficult mindset where
in the absence of more explicit violence
it's
easy to ignore that her life as a
handmaid
is itself a continuing act of bodily
violence
again abusers will use this against
their victims
there are no beatings no verbal abuse
when you just give
into what they want from you perhaps
sexually or otherwise
and suddenly that coercion doesn't feel
as much
like violence but a choice that you
consciously made to keep the peace
again they're controlling how the issue
is
framed here that it was always your
choice
and it's because of this that the first
scene in which aunt lydia appears in the
book
is really quite chilling she is an axis
around which violence happens
but is never perpetrated by her it's
janine
telling about how she was gang-raped at
14 and had an abortion
she told the same story last week at
testifying it's safer to make things up
than to say you have nothing to reveal
but whose fault was it
antolina says holding up one plump
finger
her fault her fault her fault we chant
in unison
who laid them on aren't helena beams
pleased with us
she did she did she did
and why did god allow such a terrible
thing to happen
teach her a lesson teach her a lesson
teach her a listen
last week janine burst into tears
cry baby cry baby cry baby
we meant it which is the bad part
i used to think well of myself i didn't
then
that was last week this week janine
doesn't wait for us to jared her
it was my fault and she says it was my
own fault
i led them on i deserved the pain
very good janine says anthony you
are an example angladia has perfected
the ultimate tactic of the abusive
she's weaponized the victims against one
another when we see
characters being explicitly cruel or
violent
it's rarely ever her at the start but we
know that she's responsible for this
atmosphere of mistrust guilt and
self-hatred
it's so dense that she doesn't even need
to threaten anymore
by the time we meet these characters it
has settled
like so many abusive relationships into
this horrible
passive equilibrium and it's that
unknown that makes so terrifying
how did she do this before the story
began
and will it come back because abuse can
be so pervasive
that after a time it becomes so deeply
rooted
that the victim can feel so trapped
that they'll do it to themselves this
has been one villainous scene